as a member of parliament for saint
bonifacid and as a minister i'm very
pleased to be here to start off this
important announcement
i want to begin by acknowledging that
i'm joining you from the traditional
unseated territory of the algonquin
anishinabek people
joining us today
we have prime minister justin trudeau
minister of families children and social
development karina gould
premier heather steffensen
minister of education and early
childhood learning wayne iwasco
the rodriguez
palacios family
and the manitoba child care association
executive director jody keel
our priority as a government is making
life more affordable for canadians and
today we are taking a very important
step for families in manitoba
today's announcement will have positive
and long-lasting impacts for families in
winnipeg and across manitoba
i'd like to thank the rodriguez palacios
family for joining us here today
i now like to turn it over to them to
introduce themselves and i understand
the prime minister and the premier have
a couple of questions for them
over to you
hi nice to meet you my name is jonathan
rodriguez and this is my family andrea
palacios and mike twist
this is sebastian and he's done
well uh listen it's a great to see you i
know twins can be a bit of a challenge
but it's uh wonderful how uh how was it
to try and find a child care and how
important uh was it that you uh you'd be
able to get them into uh into child care
uh was such
a challenge for us because we are a
newcomers here in canada we arrived two
years ago
and
we
we did the research
researching internet how to apply for
the daycare but we have to wait a lot of
time to get a spot and was more
difficult because there were two babies
and in many places it told us that
they have just one
spot for one of them but the idea is
that they
are together in the daycare
um finally a we found a good daycare
close to home and we are so happy so
happy because
the the guys has the opportunity to
meet new
friends and
and know the
canadian culture
premier do you have a question
am i is my mic on can you hear me yes we
can hear you okay great
um just just good morning everyone and
and thank you so much andrea and
jonathan for for being with us today
along with daniel and and sebastian it's
just great to have you here can you tell
us a little bit about what today's
announcement means to you and and how it
helps you and your family
yes of course of course
sorry
um
i could you hear me
yes we can
okay
um this program means a lot in the
budget of our family and
we were blessed with twins boys however
this also means double expenses for us
uh so now every dollar that we can save
um
help us with our future family projects
um
also it's a great news for us because
currently
my husband is working but i still
looking for a job
uh this program helps help us a lot
because we can now afford the daycare
cost is is is so good for us it's a
blessing for us it's our blessing for us
yes great
thank you so much andrea and jonathan it
was very nice to meet you today and
i'm now very pleased to welcome the
prime minister the right honorable
justin trudeau
uh it's great to see premier stefansson
and minister owasko uh happy to be
joined as well by jodi kiel the
executive director for the manitoba
child care associations uh and
especially thank you to andrea and
jonathan for uh for joining us today i
mean this announcement is all about uh
making sure that life is more affordable
for families that kids have the best
start in life and that you have the
choices and and what you said andrea
about uh being able to look for work and
and know uh that the the kids are in
in
in a good place uh while you can engage
uh in in contributing to your family
into your community is is incredibly
important so you know how important high
quality child uh child care is and we're
glad to be making this announcement
today
uh last night last summer we signed a
historic deal with manitoba we laid out
a plan to cut fees in half by the end of
this year and for 10 a day child care by
march of 2023
well today we can announce that
thousands of families will be saving
money on child care
earlier than planned
manitoba will now expand its child care
subsidy program and up to 12 000
additional children will receive support
particularly those in low and middle
income families
with this expansion nearly half of
regulated spaces in the province will
now be subsidized
families that apply and qualify to
subsidy programs should see their fees
cut by as much as 50 percent
and we're still on track to cut average
fees in half for manitoba families by
the end of this year
family
we know that costs are significant
around the country because of this
pandemic
that's where this boost will help them
with everything from groceries to gas to
what they need to get through winter at
a time that is really challenging
but it's not just families in manitoba
that are benefiting from this families
are already beginning to see savings in
other places too in nova scotia and pei
in alberta in saskatchewan and we're
really glad uh to know that families
like yours are going to be able to
benefit as well in manitoba this is real
positive change for families and the
economy and we're going to continue
working with provinces and territories
and indigenous partners to make sure
kids have the best possible start in
life and to make sure our economy comes
back in an inclusive way that gives
everyone an opportunity to succeed
specifically uh moms in this
trek
stefansson
thank you very much uh prime minister
and welcome to manitoba albeit virtually
but it's great to have you here and and
we look forward to getting together with
you in in person as soon as it's safe to
do so
uh so good morning everyone i'm very
pleased to be here uh today with with
all of you uh making what is i i think a
significant announcement for for women
for families and to ensure we are
funding a system that is sustainable now
and into the future
over the past two years we have all seen
the devastating impact of covet 19 and
what it's had
on employment on our economy and it has
been particularly hard on working women
as we have seen over the course of the
pandemic access to child care is
absolutely vital to ensuring women and
families can continue to work and
provide critical services to manitobans
and as we look toward the post-pandemic
future access to child care continues to
be a key element to rebuilding our
economy
our government along with the federal
government is committed to ensuring
working women and families have the
supports they need to return to
employment attend training programs
and return to the classroom
what no matter what path people choose
all of these choices need access to
affordable child care if we are going to
rebuild our economy
today is the first initiative under
manitoba's two-year action plan to
address the issue of affordability which
will reduce parent fees by up to 30
percent and triple the number of
subsidized
those
triple the number of subsidized spaces
in manitoba
it also ensures parents will pay on
average out-of-pocket fee of ten dollars
per day by the end of 2023.
today's announcement of the increase to
the current subsidy thresholds
is the step
is the first step towards achieving
these targets
we know that a parent's ability to
participate in the workforce may be
dependent upon access to affordable
child care
and today's announcement will allow more
manitoba families to participate in the
labor market and maintain employment
while knowing their children are
receiving safe and nurturing care
manitoba's updated income threshold for
child care subsidies ensures parents pay
what they can afford based upon their
net household income
over the course of the next two years
with support from the government of
canada and continuous consultation with
early childhood educators
i know we can build a community-based
system of quality affordable and
inclusive early learning and child care
programs and services for manitoba
families
i'll now turn it over to the minister of
families
children and social development the
honorable the honorable karina gould
over to you minister
thank you for joining us today virtually
in manitoba
thank you so much uh premier stephenson
i am glad to be joining you virtually
although of course i would prefer to be
there in person but i am joining you
today from my riding in burlington
ontario burlington is rich in history
and the modern traditions of many first
nations and the metis from yanushnabe to
the hotnashoni and the metis the lands
spanning from lake ontario to the
niagara escarpment are steeped in
indigenous history
the territory is mutually covered by the
dish with one spoon wampum belt covenant
an agreement between the iroquois
confederacy the ojibwe and other allied
nations to peaceably share and care for
the resources around the great lakes
this land is part of the treaty lands
and territory of the mississaugas of the
credit
today's announcement is great news for
manitoba families we've just heard from
andrea and jonathan just what this means
for them
and i want to acknowledge premier
stephenson and minister awasco for
moving forward on the path of accessible
and affordable high quality child care
in manitoba
for the prime minister minister vandal
myself and our whole government we know
that access to high quality affordable
flexible and inclusive child care is not
a luxury
it's a necessity
that's why our commitment to building a
canada-wide early learning and child
care system matters more than ever
canada
today's announcement is a meaningful
first step to lowering parent fees in
manitoba and will make a real difference
for families across the province
expanding the child care subsidy program
will greatly improve access to
affordable early learning and child care
for approximately 12 000 more children
particularly from low and middle income
families including 8 000 children age 6
and under
as a result more manitoba parents will
be able to participate in the labor
market and maintain employment
especially as our economy recovers from
the effects of the pandemic
grasa
the manitoba
foreign
i look forward to even more progress
especially on creating more child care
spaces and establishing a wage grid to
attract and retain early childhood
educators
and let me take a moment to acknowledge
our incredible eces
as a mom of a child in daycare myself i
know how much as parents we rely on you
to take care of our most precious
resource our children
i know the pandemic has asked a lot of
everyone but particularly our eces who
have done everything they can to keep
our kids safe and cared for in these
difficult times
so thank you to our incredible eces for
all that you do every day
i would like to profoundly thank
everyone involved in today's
announcement including the federal and
provincial officials who worked
tirelessly to make this announcement
happen
and thank you to the child care
advocates and champions in manitoba for
helping us get to this historic
agreement in your province and across
the country
on that note i'll turn it over to
minister awasko to say a few words
minister congratulations on the new rule
over to you
thank you uh very much minister gold and
i would at first like to acknowledge
that we here in manitoba are on treaties
one two three four and five lands which
are the traditional territories of the
anishinaabe cree
ojikri dakota and danae peoples and of
course the homeland of the metis nation
i am absolutely thrilled to be here with
our federal and provincial partners to
make this incredible announcement that
will reduce out-of-pocket expenses and
fees for so many manitoba families
i also want to acknowledge our
provincial partners from the manitoba
child care association thank you to
president karen laflesche for your
ongoing collaboration with our
government and of course
the fantastic executive director jody
kale for joining us virtually here today
today are expanding our eligibility to
our child care subsidy program
which has not been re-indexed since
2012.
this has resulted in fewer families
receiving child care subsidies as the
income thresholds did keep pace with
minimum wage adjustments to reflect
increased costs of living
with this change in eligibility it is
estimated that an additional 12 000
children will receive support to access
regulated child care
particularly in low and middle income
families
this means that we are tripling the
number of children currently supported
in regulated child care
with the support of the federal
government we are able to provide
sustainability
more substantially more families with
assistance
during and ensuring that low and middle
income manitobans have access to child
care to advance their ability to
participate and maintain employment
the child care subsidy income threshold
is increasing by 45
from an average household income of 23
000 to just over 37 000
for a full subsidy or from 37 000
to just under 83 000 for a partial
subsidy
this change in income threshold will
result in nearly half of regulated
spaces being subsidized and will reduce
out-of-pocket parent fees by 30 percent
today's announcement aligns with key
priorities to support manitoba's early
learning and child care transformation
strategy
this strategy balances affordable child
care fees with financial assistance
financial assistance providers through a
modernized equitable funding approach
before i conclude i would like to
acknowledge the hard-working and
dedicated staff in our early learning
and child care sector
they are valuable in ensuring our
children are cared for
so parents can participate in the
workforce or attend training and
education programs
to further invest strengthen and
stabilize our early childhood educator
workforce we are finalizing the new
workforce addendum in partnership with
the federal government
this will offer a one-time investment to
initiate longer-term planning and
supports for the workforce and we look
forward to making that announcement soon
as the new minister of education
and early childhood learning i look
forward to connecting directly with
early childhood educators
teachers school
school staff and administration as we
move forward with the alignment of our
child care and education sectors
thank you and i will now turn it back
over to minister of northern affairs
minister responsible of prairies
economic development canada and minister
responsible for the canadian northern
economic development agency the
honourable dan vandell
thank you so much
minister iwasko and and merci premier
ministrudo menace gould
premier ministeffensen uh le nouvello
georges it is excellent nouvelle
polyfamily at winnipeg ao manitoba
thank you to the rodriguez palacios
family for joining us today to share
your important story
and to jodi kiel for being a tireless
advocate
for child care here in manitoba
this now concludes this formal
announcement and i'll turn it over to
the moderated media availability merci
beaucoup
merci good morning
we have 20 minutes for questions with
the prime minister and premier
stephenson
we'll start with questions in the room
for 10 minutes and then go to reporters
on zoom for 10.
we'll have an additional 10 minutes
following that for questions with
ministers five minutes in the room five
minutes for zoom
reporters will have one question and one
follow-up
i will now pass it to the room to begin
questions
uh 12 000 additional children will be
subsidized here um the goal is obviously
to get to that sort of 10 a day
day daycare how how much is this going
to or i guess
how much is this going to cost these
families
sure
thanks ian for the question and and
moving forward we're talking about
you know this program that's that's
going to be over the next two years and
then as we're working with our
stakeholders and this is a joint program
with the federal government uh in
regards to working towards that
10 a day day care as you already know
across the country our daycare fees are
are
very very affordable already uh but at
the same time with the help of the
federal government we're definitely
moving to that uh to that 10 a day day
care per uh per child how much will it
cost what's it subsidized for these
families
overall are you are you meaning as far
as uh total from the provincial side or
federal side or where per family how
much is our families going to pay once
for these 12 000 additional families how
much are they going to pay so they're
going to
a little bit more of the fine details i
guess will i can get back to you on
but
it could be as as low as as low as two
dollars which is a uh absolute uh
i guess the initial fee and uh you know
could be higher than that depending on
where they fall in the uh subsidy uh
categories
how was the determination made for the
threshold eligibility for the two uh
two two numbers there based on household
income how did you determine those being
the the windows of a possible income
that would be able to apply for this
so i think under uh under the last few
months working with the federal
government and also
with the department of of families which
is now
synergized under the under the new
department of education and early
childhood learning they came up with the
uh with the figures and i believe that
they've worked with the department of
finance as well to see where those
numbers would uh would line up
for the premier or the prime minister
just this announcement we're making
today where we're at do you think we
would be here on our our movement
towards dollar a day uh child care if it
wasn't for the pressures being put on
the system parents the economy from the
pandemic i think one thing certainly uh
the pandemic has has um maybe brought
this to the forefront and how important
i mean we've always known how important
the child care sector is but i think
just just knowing and the incredible
work that they did
um you know during the pandemic has just
been amazing and i know we've worked
closely with with jody and others in in
the industry as well and and just how
important that is and and so yeah i
think this is a great opportunity for us
to work together with the federal
government and uh i think this is great
for manitoba families
prime minister
yeah no thank you thank you for you to
to build on that
there have been many many people who've
long known how important uh child care
is both to give kids the best start in
life to support uh families with uh
affordable costs and good quality of
living but also to support the economy
and
a lot of extraordinarily strong
advocates and activists have been
working for many many years to improve
child care and quite frankly uh manitoba
has already
shown itself to be a leader among
different provinces on on
affordable child care but this pandemic
really woke everyone up in the business
community
across the political spectrum to say
wow we need to make sure
we have affordable high quality child
care and it was really the uh the
impetus that uh that allowed us to put
forward historic investment in the last
budget uh and uh to work so directly
with so many provinces uh manitoba was
among the among the first uh to move
forward to really bring costs down for
for canadians and quite frankly at a
time where we know the costs are going
up for families in so many areas saving
hundreds of dollars a month thousands of
dollars a year on child care costs uh
can only make a huge difference uh for
families right across the country uh and
include right here in manitoba
premier can you please talk about how
you're going to step how the subsidized
spaces are going to be staffed what's
the plan for making sure there are
enough people with training eces who can
do the work i know a lot of them the pay
isn't great and a lot of them are
leaving like they're going to other jobs
as tas in the school system so how are
we going to find the people to work at
these high quality uh early learning
centers yeah thanks very much for that
carol and i'll maybe pass it over to
minister owasko but i know that this is
the first of a few announcements that
will be made over the course of the next
little while i hate to say stay tuned
carol because i know you don't like when
i say that
but i we do have some great
opportunities i think moving forward mr
owasko do you want to add an ad on
absolutely and and carol thanks for that
question because i think that's that's
definitely on many people's minds and as
the prime minister mentioned in regards
to
you know as we're moving out of this
pandemic and how tough it's been on
on families over the last couple of
years dealing with covet and then you
know trying to get the you know more
affordable daycare and and again as the
prime minister mentioned you know
manitoba has been a leader in the
country as far as affordable daycare
spaces already um and with this this is
just going to help even more to put you
know to to relieve some of those
financial pressures but carol to answer
your question as the premier mentioned
there is more good news coming so
definitely stay tuned but in addition to
that we're we are making sure that that
we're working with the sector and and
i'm i'm thrilled that uh
that uh jody kale has joined us here
today as well but we're we're looking at
basically the affordability the quality
and of course the workforce and so
within the next
few months we're going to get some
additional good news for the sector so
that we can definitely try to train and
retain
the individuals that we need to be
working with with our
as i think mr gould said our most uh
precious resource our our kids here in
the province manitoba
there was a pretty specific announcement
about a page hop up for i think it was
ece twos i'm not sure is that still
going ahead and uh or has that changed
so carol again um
definitely working with the sector and
and uh just showing again that that our
government has been a a very listening
and collaborative uh government and and
uh especially under under uh premier
stephenson moving forward we're working
with the child care sector and and uh
that good news uh is potentially coming
uh shortly
um is this supposed to kick in today or
when is it starting i suppose i think
the prime minister wanted to say
something yeah
just saying it was a core piece of the
agreements we signed across the country
yes uh bringing the price down to ten
dollars a day yes uh creating new spaces
uh for families that need them but also
specifically investing in early
childhood educators because we know
their core and key to having a quality
system that is doing right by by
families and i i know manitoba's been
working hard on that and we we support
them fully in in moving forward and in
whatever future announcements they're
able to make
last question in the room here yeah my
question is when is this supposed to
start and i guess how long do families
have to apply for this
great
so if i if i may premiere uh so february
6th and uh probably uh roughly about 40
minutes ago um some of the information
go went live on on the website
and so if anybody's got a pen jotting
this down the website is www.gov.mb.ca
forward slash fs forward slash
child care
and
that will also be moving into an
education
and early childhood learning website in
the near future but
thanks for that
you can go to zoom
thank you we will start with questions
uh from zoom
come on
marika walsh globe and mail
good morning prime minister turning to
the protests in ottawa would you ever
consider sending the army in to end the
protests is that an option that you
think is viable
our focus is on being there to support
the police of jurisdiction
support the city of ottawa and the
government of ontario we will of course
uh look at any uh formal requests uh
they sent us uh but uh in in
our preoccupation uh remains uh being
there for uh the citizens of ottawa uh
the neighborhoods that have been
significantly disrupted by these
protests and by these protesters uh
people going to school people going to
work small business owners being
harassed for wearing masks being faced
with hateful rhetoric
as a federal government uh the rcmp has
been there to provide support to the uh
to the
police of jurisdiction
ottawa police
and of course uh we will be there to
respond to any uh formal requests from
either the city or the province
i'm left um unclear in understanding
whether you think the military though is
an option are you saying that
that you would be or you are
entertaining or could be the next prime
minister trudeau to deploy the military
within canada for such a demonstration
there were questions uh a couple of
years ago around uh military uh when it
came to other protests that were
blocking critical infrastructures uh my
answer then uh can take is consistent
with my answer now uh that uh one has to
be very very cautious before
deploying uh military in in situations
uh engaging canadians uh it is not
something uh that anyone should enter in
likely uh uh lightly uh but uh as of now
there have been no uh requests and and
that is not in the cards right now
melanie marquis
melanie you might be on mute
okay
foreign
next question ryan to multi national
post
yeah good morning sir um i'm wondering
with the scale of the protest and i know
you're in isolation for covid right now
but with the scale of the protest and
the way it is blocking the parliamentary
precinct
are you confident that if you wanted to
you could get to the house of commons
safely
to be honest ryan i'm much more
concerned uh about uh the citizens of
ottawa who are increasingly being very
vocal about the fact that this needs to
stop
we've seen uh seniors step forward uh
we've seen young families being very
very vocal about the fact that this is
absolutely unacceptable
this is uh protesting people going about
their daily lives uh harassing people
who dare wear masks or follow public
health rules uh ex
expressing uh hateful uh uh
approaches uh you know showing hateful
symbols of genocide of racism
these are things that are absolutely
unacceptable and the people of ottawa
deserve to have their lives back deserve
to have their neighborhoods back
as a federal government um you know
there are constitutional uh requirements
on how we intervene in local
jurisdictions uh and that's why we are
there to provide support uh as necessary
uh with the rcmp uh with uh intelligence
services uh we know that this people of
ottawa deserve to have their lives back
and this is a time for responsible
leadership as well for all uh
politicians from all parties to tell
these protesters as i have that it's
time to
get uh
back to uh
back to normal in the city of ottawa
that people of ottawa uh who are just
trying to live their lives and who are
suffering through this pandemic like
everyone is across this country
it's time to give them their
neighborhoods back
the protest groups have called
for
a sit down with your government they've
called for negotiations they've
obviously called for an end to mandates
is there any scenario in which you'd be
willing to negotiate with these
protesters to have them leave
um
we will remain steadfast to the mandate
given to parliamentarians six months ago
in the last election
you will remember that there were very
very clear differences of opinion
around mandatory vaccination around
vaccine mandates uh put forward in that
election and they were heavily debated
and indeed
protested by some of the main people who
are sending people who are protesting
right now in ottawa and the commitment
that we made as a government if we got
reelected is we would stand by science
we would continue to do what it takes to
protect people through this and
vaccinated federal public servants be
fully vaccinated move forward with
faxing mandates in federally regulated
areas
that is the promise we made to canadians
that is the decision canadians took in
the last election by voting for parties
that were supporting
those mandates
so um
having a group of people who disagree
with the outcome of an election who want
to uh you know go a different way and
bring in an alternative government um
is a non-starter in a responsible
democracy
that is why we are continuing to fulfill
the responsibility that uh
the the uh the canadians gave us in this
last election and quite frankly continue
to stand by the almost 90 of truckers
who are vaccinated stand by the millions
upon millions of canadians
who just want to get their lives back
and who know
that getting back
to the things we love
requires vaccinations
we have time for one last question from
zoom for the prime
my question will be for uh premier
stevenson uh what do you think of the
appointment of candice bergen as an term
leader of the conservative party uh some
of her comments were criticized earlier
this week when she compared the presence
of nazi flags and the truck convoy to
the removal of queen victoria's statue
what's your uh what do you think of this
so what the federal conservative party
is is what's happening with that is is
their business
you know certainly in manitoba we have a
number of things that are on the
forefront of of what we're focusing on
uh when it comes to uh covid and when it
comes to you know healthcare when it
comes to getting our economy back up and
running those are the things that we're
focusing on obviously when it comes to
you know people who are you know waving
around nazi flags and this kind of thing
we have no no time for that at all i've
said that
i don't have any time for violent
behavior
wherever it is and we don't condone that
kind of behavior
so
follow up
on the appointment
um
[Music]
um i look forward to speaking with uh
interim leader candice bergen uh in the
uh
shortly uh to congratulate her for new
responsibilities but to highlight how
important it is that all
parliamentarians work together that all
parties work together to deliver for
canadians to help canadians get through
this pandemic that means
uh working on uh supporting the public
health
advice and measures put in place um it's
a time for responsible leadership
and i certainly hope that the
conservative party uh under its uh uh
its current direction uh will uh put
that responsibility first and foremost
in the choice it makes and in how it uh
you know encourages uh all canadians to
get through this pandemic uh safely by
being there for each other and not
disrespecting or harassing one another
thank you that concludes the portion of
the press conference with the prime
minister and premier stephenson
ministers will remain online for an
additional 10 minutes starting with five
minutes in the room and five minutes on
zoom
concludes
steffensen
is
i will turn it over to the room for five
minutes with ministers
uh minister owaspo i i know you may say
that there is an announcement to come
but but the fact that provincial funding
for child care centers those grants have
not increased since 2016.
is that concerning to you
so thanks uh thanks for that question is
it concerning
the uh the fees and and the funding and
that and that's why
you know i might even turn it over to uh
to miss kale right away
government moving forward i mean as you
know when we took uh took power in 2016
we we were looking at a
960 980 million dollar
uh
debt at that time
and so we worked hard to try to uh bring
that back to balance under premiere
palester and and um and so now moving
forward again listening to the sector
working with them quite closely i think
with the new move um
that that premier stephenson did on
creating the new department of education
and
early childhood learning i think brings
great synergies to the sector and also
to the department i think both of them
complement one another and i think
moving forward making sure that that
our daycare spaces are are
affordable we've got high quality we've
all we're gonna we're gonna
improve on already what's there the high
quality services that our early
childhood
educators are providing our our children
in the in the daycare system and then
we'll we'll also be working on that on
that workforce and and uh taking a look
at those those different uh wages as
well and so i'm encouraged and i think
the sector's encouraged in in the uh in
the partnership and the working together
and moving forward for
for a more uh again affordable
sustainable and uh
and
um quality uh child care system right
here in manitoba
can you minister just talk about why the
quality is important you're the minister
uh now who's in charge of this portfolio
and
education and you were advanced
education so can you just talk about
what it's going to mean for the young
family they see for their kids now where
do you see them in 12 years or grade 12
as a result of this like is there any
expectation that that's a great question
uh and and it's almost like we uh
we work together on that question
because it it uh i think again as i was
saying the synergy between early
childhood education and learning uh with
the education department i mean we all
know that the the k-12 system is there
and and we're working on again uh
working closely with our stakeholders
our education partners and i think now
with the sector of early childhood
learning within the department i think
those uh those
those collaborations and discussions are
are going to be able to happen uh more
quickly and and more readily available
we've heard for years i mean
before i i became an mla
i was a guidance counselor and a teacher
you know for 17 years
heard many times when i would go to
post-secondary
information days for guidance counselors
and that on
on the on the quality or the or the
various types of education that our kids
are getting at uh the students are
getting at k to 12.
and so i think that that synergy with
with the
the conversations happening within
government the collaboration with with
the various presidents and the and the
education leaders within the province i
think are are paramount
and
at the end of the day the goal is to uh
to have
high quality education moving forward
here in manitoba and making sure that
we're ready post pandemic
so uh back you know carol you mentioned
um
when i was uh advanced education skills
and immigration minister we launched the
skills talent and knowledge strategy
back february of 2021
i think uh you know moving forward
that's that's not just a whole of
government approach that's an absolutely
whole of manitoba approach north east
south and west where we have to make
sure that we've got highly trained
individuals and we're going to work hard
right here in manitoba to train and
retain
our our students and and anyone else
who's looking for some form of education
whether that's early learning whether
that's k-12 or whether that's a
post-secondary education so i'm actually
uh
as you can tell i think more than more
than thrilled with the appointment of of
this department and bringing in early
childhood learning as well one more
question uh for jody kell just curious
if you could share some of your thoughts
and feelings on the announcement today
from your perspective
so okay mr gould
yes please go ahead okay
thank you for that question i mean i
mean clearly today's announcement is is
prioritizing affordability for families
like andrea and jonathan's and so that's
going to make child care far more
affordable for many manitoba families
and that's really welcome news but we've
heard today that affordability although
it's a critical part of system building
it's one component of system building
and we know that system building of a
high quality early learning and child
care system is multi-dimensional and so
i'm encouraged today to hear from both
the government of canada
and from manitoba that early learning
and child work for
prior to right
you know early childhood educators and
home-based providers are the foundation
to which our system exists and so when
we talk about high quality child care at
the heart of high quality child care is
educated
and well remunerated
early childhood educators and so the
centerpiece of our plan and of the
canada-wide plan um has to encompass a
workforce strategy um it it will not be
transformative without that strategy and
so mcc is is is anxious to hear and it's
exciting to hear about upcoming and much
needed investments into
the existing workforce so that they can
continue to do the wonderful important
work that they have done throughout the
pandemic that they've been doing for
hundreds of years in manitoba and in our
country and we've continued to say for
the last 24 months that thanks to child
care manitoba works
that's all the time
so we'll go to zoom oh
yeah okay great um so just building on
um jody's comments and minister wasco's
comments um
as as she mentioned i think very well is
that the
canada-wide early learning and child
care initiative
is based on a number of principles
affordability is important accessibility
quality and inclusive and inclusivity
and all of those four components need to
be part of this in order for it to be
the success that we want it to be and
what does that mean it means that not
only do we need to lower the fees which
today is a wonderful step
in that direction but it means we also
have to increase spaces but we can't
increase spaces if we don't have
qualified eces and providers to do that
and we need to ensure that there is high
quality and again that means training
and retaining
those ece and we want to ensure that
it's inclusive which means that whether
it's in
the official language of
the individual who requires that child
care whether it's with regards to um
indigenous children and that it is
available to them and so this is one
step along that path and it's a really
important one and we heard today the
meaningful difference it's going to make
for andrea and jonathan and their two
kids um in terms of their ability to
put their kids in child care and for
andrea's ability to get back into the
workforce those are really important
parts of this but it's one part of the
overall plan and it's why early learning
is part of the title because we do see
this as a continuation of setting our
kids up for success
we'll turn it to zoom
thank you very much we now go to the
brandon sun and colin slark
good morning my first question is for
minister wasco wasco
last year
excuse me uh last year the province's
child care wait list was decommissioned
i was wondering what the plan is to keep
track of
what families are going to be uh
having positions made available to them
uh with
today's announcement
thanks uh
thanks colin for that for that question
so so as you've already heard and and i
appreciate minister gould and uh and um
and jody kale for for putting uh
a few words on the record here as well
and and i look forward to continuing to
work with both of them as we move
forward with this great fed prov
uh announcement today as you've heard uh
we we're talking about affordability
we're talking about quality and we're
talking of course uh workforce so right
now we're looking at we've got about 38
000 spaces with today's announcement
we're looking at almost 50 percent of
those
um
children will be will be subsidized
uh so we're looking at that 10 a day
average uh coming into full force and
maybe even sooner by uh the end of march
2023
so we are looking at exactly how
minister gould said
you you can lower and
make child care even more affordable
than manitoba was already producing
but with that you do have to look at
child care spaces and we have committed
to increasing our child care spaces
right here in the province and again
with that you need to train and retain
so we need to encourage individuals to
get into the profession of early
childhood education
and we're going to be doing that working
with the sector
on different strategies on how we
encourage we get to those schools and we
get to you know talk to the public about
getting them interested into this and
and part of that is going to be that uh
that that
wage scale and that but we're going to
uh
wait for a little bit till that great
good news comes out and uh and with that
we'll we'll continue on our on our
journey and and as mr gould said and uh
jody kale said this is the first step of
uh a few more to come
thank you my follow-up question is for
minister gould
this morning the parliamentary budget
office released a report on the
projected costs of the federal national
child care plan
but it also stated that it was not able
to fully determine the cost for all
elements of the plan due to a lack of
available policy details um what does
your government estimate will be the
complete cost of this national program
yeah it's a great question brandon and
first of all i want to thank the pbo for
doing this important work
and we're at the beginning of the
journey on this we are building a
canada-wide early learning and child
care system we have some great data
from the province of quebec
that you know we can use to estimate and
see where we're going and that's quite
frankly um you know what we based the
canada-wide
initiative on and so we know that uh
with this about 30 billion dollar
program over the next five years that we
can achieve our objectives when it comes
to affordability when it comes to
accessibility inclusivity and quality
and so in manitoba you know we're
talking about about 1.2 billion dollars
over the next five years uh that means
we're going to make childcare more
affordable get to that average ten
dollars a day manitoba's tracking
towards that by march 2023 we're going
to increase the number of spaces we're
going to be able to train at ece and
bring forward a wage grid to retain them
and provide additional supports and
we're going to keep working on quality
because uh when we talk about early
learning and child care we're not just
talking about babysitting we're talking
about actual child early childhood
development as well so you know parents
want to know that their kid is safe
they're being well looked after but
they're also building those blocks that
they need to have a strong foundation as
they grow so um
you know we we have this fantastic
agreement with manitoba we've got
agreements with 12 provinces and
territories and we look forward to
finalizing that last agreement as well
from ctv winnipeg
jeff
oh hello uh following up on that last
answer uh i i understand what you're
saying that
you know you're going to be looking at
adding spaces
and the wage wages for to attract and
retain a staff
but as of today child care could be free
if a parent can't find child care for
their parent today
then then it doesn't matter so what's
the timeline what's the plan because
we've had long wait lists for years and
years and years and years and parents
are frustrated so what is the plan
what's the timeline across the country
in manitoba
to open up more spaces so a parent can
send their child
in their neighborhood to daycare
absolutely let me
let me take a first stab at that one so
um
as i think is really important i mean we
signed this agreement with manitoba six
months ago so it's pretty impressive i
think that they've made such great
progress in terms of affordability
within six months that is a great thing
and it's going to help 12 000 children
additional children in
manitoba
as of monday who will be able to apply
for this subsidy so that's a really good
step in terms of affordability but our
plan is over five years and so there are
milestones along the way in terms of
when
we want to see provinces and territories
including manitoba meet those objectives
so the first one that we committed to
and we've asked provinces and
territories to commit to is a 50
reduction in fees by the end of this
calendar year
manitoba's well on their way to
achieving that the second one is to see
a fee reduction by 10 to 10 an average
of 10 a day by 25 26. manitoba has
committed to doing that by march of 2023
so within the next year and of course as
was mentioned you know manitoba already
has lower fees than many other
jurisdictions um in canada so they're
further ahead but where we need to
continue to do that work is on
supporting workforce and you know i'm
committed to working with minister
owasko
um and his government on doing that so
supporting workforce the wage grid that
will be announced um support and
training and professional development
for eces
we need to do further work on quality
and inclusivity
and these are all things that
take a bit of time because you have to
train more ece before you can open
additional spaces and so we've committed
to over the next five years at different
benchmarks and milestones as to when
additional spaces need to be reached but
the objective is to get to a 59 coverage
rate um within five years so that is the
objective and i hear you um and i think
we heard very clearly from andrea and
jonathan that it's very challenging and
stressful uh to find a daycare space
especially when you have to return to
work and add on to that if you have two
kids of the same age and not just one um
you know i went through that with my son
uh you know and
most places that i spoke to and i think
you know jonathan said it very well they
had one spot but they might not have two
so i think we all understand how
important um building and opening new
spaces is and that is one of the
objectives and priorities with the
canada-wide early learning and child
care system that we are building with
the province of manitoba
and our final question this morning does
go to jeff please
proceed
oh hi is is um minister vandell still
still part of this
yes i am
okay just could you update us on the uh
provinces and the city's application
for the infrastructure funding for the
north and water pollution control center
is is the federal government looking
favorable on that
we are looking very favorable on that
issue as you know
the environment and climate change is uh
is a pillar of our platform across all
ministries we know this is something
that's been in the works for a long time
in fact i was public works chair back in
uh 2000 and uh
and 11 or 10 i think and submitted the
application
uh
i i would need to uh get back to you
jeff on where it everything is right now
but we are going to do all things
necessary to expedite this
and make sure we announce the next phase
as quickly as we can
thank you minister and thanks to
everyone this concludes our news
conference
thank you
you